i didn't even know how to process it i
i showed my boyfriend he was just like
that's it's
that's oprah and i was like i mean
i i we both just like stared each other
for like a minute and then
i got a text from my brother who was
like it's basically as close as you can
get to god so you should be proud of
yourself
she stumbled on upon a little girl's
fairy garden and made everybody's world
a little brighter
kelly kenny aka sapphire and emily pauls
aka eliana's mom
you both thank you so much for taking
time out of your week to join us and
thank you for spreading joy during
a time that we really needed especially
on
social media what a whirlwind week for
you both
how are you all doing going viral or
like you know
being a part of this viral sensation is
just as much fun as it is exhausting
so yeah it's been it's been a ride it's
been a lot but i'm trying to
it's like emily said it's been a really
fun ride at the same time kelly if you
can
take us back to that night you know
you're walking some feelings out outside
you stumble upon a fairy garden
start at the beginning and talk us
through this whole experience
okay well yeah i've been going through
some a rough patch and
definitely couldn't sleep so i was just
going out around the neighborhood for
walks at night
and listening to music and i would just
kind of go up and down the street and
at the end of my street i found this
little fairy garden it was actually the
little pinwheel that caught my attention
and i was like
where's that and looked down and
realized how
well set up all of it was and how cute
all the little notes were
on the tree that emily had left about
her daughter who had created the garden
and i was just so touched
and since the beginning of the pandemic
i've thought about
how it's affecting the children i mean
we keep talking about
how it's affecting all of us and nobody
has talked
a whole lot about how this is going to
affect them
and and their like ability to process
things in the future and what they think
about all of this growing up are they
going to be
traumatized or super paranoid um
so i've kept that in mind that this
entire time and so seeing that
and finding that note and thinking about
her
not able to go to the park not able to
go to school or see her friends
just made me want to try to do something
a little bit special for her
so i had no idea if she was going to see
it or not but i
it made me i started smiling on my walk
home thinking about
what my very name should be so
yeah what did that first message say
the first message said um that i was a
fairy who would come to live in the tree
because
she had made it so pretty and that
i was given wizard dice or dice from a
wizard
magical dice and that if she could do
these four things for me then i would
leave them for her
wow i had started making dice in
quarantine and so i had like a box of
ones that weren't
totally perfect or didn't come out of
the molds perfectly so i was like
these are all sparkly she might like
these so
we put it out there um our whole
community has really come around it
and had been putting things in the
garden and so
um so we would always actually we would
go on our daily walks in the morning
and we always would check the fairy
garden to see if there's anything new
and see what's going on and um people
had left like little thank you notes and
stuff like that before
and so um but yeah this one was
different because
kelly made it super cute like put it in
a little bottle and
had like some fairy dust in it and so
yeah eliana was super excited and she
sprinkled all the dust on the
on the on the fairy garden and she was
like you know
the protest and then um yeah and then
she we did those things that day like it
was like it was really sweet like little
tasks like do
five nice things for somebody you care
about or do you know and so
we wrote we we wrote her a note back
with what those things were
she drew a picture and we like set it
back in the little bottle
and yeah and then the dice were there in
the morning the next morning so
so how long did this go back and forth
how many notes were there in exchanges
were there before you guys were able to
safely meet up in person you think emily
like 20
[Laughter]
there were there was a number yeah maybe
like 15
20 interactions i didn't want to
overwhelm them and have it be like every
single night i still wanted it to be a
little bit magical so
um yeah i tried to give them some space
too
wow was sapphire the talk of your
household i would imagine
eliana probably was just solely focused
on that for the whole time being right
oh yeah i mean she still talks about
sapphire and like just the other day
she's like i want to go visit her and
her new tree
and all this stuff because we talked
about she moved and
all this stuff so yeah i mean then she
she'll tell anyone who'll
listen about it so oh my goodness well
good thing there's social media does she
does she understand what's happening and
how
the world is so touched by this story
not a clue not a clue i i mean we were
kind of like trying to figure out like
how to
like you know especially as we were like
grappling with it the first like day we
were like wow this is cool like
we should say kind of like i don't know
how to like really tell her about it so
we kind of just said hey like
you know we share this your story was
you know or like the little book that
she wrote like well like these things
were shared and like
and so many people saw it and all this
stuff and she looks at me and she's like
i
don't understand what you're saying
um but yeah we couldn't fathom like so
many people she thinks that
a thousand twelve is like the biggest
number and so she go i was like i
thought
i was like more than a thousand twelve
people i've seen this and she's like
wow oh my goodness
kelly when did you realize this
started making a difference in your
quarantine and kind of what you were
going through
after the first couple exchanges i
i realized that i was i had something to
look forward to i was sitting there like
oh i could do this oh i should order
more glitter oh you know it'd be really
cool if i found like a little bracelet
and
and left that and then it would be a
whole nother scavenger hunt or like
i realized that i was sitting there and
and like super excited
to write the next letter and to see what
she said because her
her responses were incredible every
single time
so and her mom's handwriting is like
incredibly beautiful i keep telling her
that but i was like mine is like super
scribbly every single letter and i felt
so bad that she's like learning to read
and trying to read my handwriting but
what would you say this experience has
meant for
you and your daughter it's just been
such a treasure
getting to know kelly through these
exchanges i mean all of
all of the persona of sapphire just is
kelly you know
just in fairy form and so i felt like
we've really gotten close to her
and felt like she's part of our family
in so many ways
um and so it's just been really
beautiful
and i've like i mean we we were already
set to treasure this experience forever
you know like
viral or not this was this is so
meaningful to us
and so um yeah and it's it's just been
i don't know like this friendship has
given eliana i know
like a ton of confidence in different
ways and i know that kelly has really
drawn out a lot of
a lot of her creativity and really
encouraged things it's been i mean
something as a parent like we we love
and don't on our children we love
like i see how amazing is the best and
it's just
it's just it's another thing to have
someone else especially someone who we
you know
have only just met through these
exchanges like be able to see that
in her and encourage that and so that's
mental it meant a ton to
to us as parents and and to eleanor you
know
kelly what's it like to hear that well
i'm trying not to cry i keep talking
i've been crying all day
um i mean i haven't been able to see any
of my family i had to cancel two
flights back home to norway to visit my
family and to see any of them and i
can't visit anybody else
so having them as my little pseudo
family right now
has just been incredible and all the
things we have in common
like we had no idea and the fact that
they
have been playing dungeons and dragons
with her which is what the dice are for
that i was making i was like
these people are so cool but of course
like only the coolest parents would be
doing this kind of thing with their kids
so
um yeah each each time we've
corresponded it's been like well me too
well we do that too
like everything is just having having
them
and hearing her say it too just yeah
how did the in-person meeting come about
and what was that experience like when
you finally were able to connect
safely in person i was telling emily
while i was sitting in my car
how nervous i was because i was like i
don't want her to be afraid of me
i don't know i don't even know what to
say i don't want her to like clam up and
like run away from me
so when i walked up they we had kind of
been texting
and it was funny i saw them find the
note and they kind of walked away and i
was like okay i'm gonna get out of the
car now
and um walked over and put the package
down and when i looked over my shoulder
and saw her looking at me i
could have totally just broken down in
tears the way she looked at me
but i didn't want to scare her so i i
wanted to get down onto her level and
just
say you know are you eliana oh no you
caught me leaving the gift
so i i was like totally at a loss for
words my hands were shaking and
at first i could tell she was a little
unsure and nervous but
like after a few minutes we just
immediately were chatting like
there we had always been there together
so
um yeah seeing her was incredibly
emotional
for me and i was trying so hard not to
cry emily i have to ask do you guys have
a fairy garden at the new house
good question yeah we've we've talked
about about making our new fare again i
just put we just put something out it's
like we don't have the same
like access to like the you know like uh
like a like a tree like in front like on
the sidewalk kind of thing but we're
we're working on that but we have a
little tree in our in our front yard
where we put a couple things
just today so well maybe one of these
days
uh queen oprah could possibly drop
something off for you guys i have to ask
you
oh my gosh reaction when you saw
oprah tweeted at you guys and invited
you to disneyland
i i didn't even know how to process it i
i showed my boyfriend he was just like
that's
that's oprah and i was like i i mean
we both just like stared at each other
for like a minute and then i got a text
from my brother who was like
it's basically as close as you can get
to god so you should be proud of
yourself
so yeah still mind-blowing
wow emily what were your guys's thoughts
oh i was
i was yeah i don't know flabbergasted
doesn't like cover it where i was just
like looking at my phone
i didn't i'm not even on twitter i
literally got a twitter
like a day ago because i was like maybe
i should figure this out i don't know
but kelly like texted it to me you know
first all i saw was oprah i just was
like
um and i didn't even read what she said
and then i
and then i showed my husband he's like
did you see what oprah said and i was
like
oh my gosh like
this is incredible so i don't know
does eliana know who oprah is
um you know what it's funny um i sent
kelly back one of like the oprah gifts
you know like the
she's so excited and she was like what
is it what is it she wanted to see that
so she knows that that
gift is oprah and she
yeah but she has no idea eliana has a
great memory already
um and but this is no for
no doubt is gonna be cemented into her
memory forever yeah and i'm not going
anywhere
[Music]
you